ces deux dernières années l'industrie
aéronautique et spatiale européenne a
été l'objet de grandes manoeuvres de
restructurations fusions et
regroupements destiné à rendre ces
entreprises plus compétitives sur le
plan mondial face aux américains
notamment par exemple aérospatiale et
matra se sont associés avec l'allemand
dasa pour donner naissance à eads
une entreprise de dimension mondiale qui
a permis de lancer le programme de
l'airbus géant l'a380
en revanche dans le secteur des moteurs
d'avion pareil restructuration se fait
attendre
ce matin le premier ministre qui
visitait le salon du bourget a lancé le
processus de privatisation de snecma
l'état détient actuellement 98 % du
capital pour lui permettre de jouer un
rôle de premier plan dans le
regroupement des motoristes européens
il fallait procéder à une ouverture de
ce capital cette ouverture d'environ un
quart du capital de l'entreprise
permettra à celle-ci de participer
activement au processus de consolidation
européenne attendues dans ce secteur
cette ouverture permettra également aux
salariés de l'entreprise d'être
davantage associé au succès industriel
de ce groupe dont l'état reste
l'actionnaire largement majorité les
trente sept mille employés de snecma
produisent des équipements et des
réacteurs d'avions militaires
mais surtout le réacteur civil le plus
vendu dans le monde
le cfm56 ses ingénieurs fabrique
également les moteurs de la fusée ariane
cette privatisation devrait donner à
l'entreprise la puissance nécessaire
pour faire face à une concurrence de
plus en plus sévères